todo listo y preparado aquí en Moscú
para la firma de anexión de los
territorios ocupados por Rusia zaporiya
y jerson las nuevas conquistas de
Vladimir Putin pero también la República
Popular de idóneas y la República
Popular de lugares que esperan su turno
desde el año 2014 se han cerrado las
calles en torno al kremlin y también se
han colocado pantallas Gigantes y
pancartas en la plaza roja que dan la
bienvenida a los nuevos territorios
Putin firmará la anexión y Rusia se
asoma a un futuro incierto con unas
fronteras que han crecido pero que al
mismo tiempo van a pasar a ser más
borrosas porque la mayor parte de los
países del mundo no las van a reconocer
aún así el kremín ha dicho que van a
seguir adelante y que van a defender
además estos nuevos territorios con todo
el armamento que tengan incluido el
nuclear